how to balance your life and your work
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
zonato25 who wrote in to say i'm a 16
year old entrepreneur and one of my
biggest misunderstood concepts
is about living your life sometimes i
want to party celebrate have fun or even
travel listen some loud music
but at the same time i wish to improve
in my personal skills study and work
more one day to be remembered by some
great contribution i've done to
humankind my question is
how can i have fun and live life at the
same time
i'm working or studying so this is a
great question i love this question
and i'm going to do my best to answer
this in a video i have a whole series of
zuga guides on time management that i
think will really help break this down
i'm gonna try to do this in a short
video for you
so i have three ideas for you okay three
rules to follow
the first one is follow your passion
number one is follow your passion and
you need to be doing things in your life
or in your business
or at school that that you're passionate
about that you love doing
when you are not doing something that
you're passionate about life sucks
okay and this is an interesting case
because
that passion may change in your business
you might get really excited about
something
and that lasts for a certain amount of
time but then that may switch
you know i i've been involved in a
number of projects that i was really
excited about at the start
and then the passion dove i wasn't
interested anymore
and that's when you don't just force
yourself to keep going on it you swerve
and find a different direction
there's some projects that i've loved
doing that i still love doing like these
videos
i still love doing these videos i love
helping you guys out and so i keep doing
it you know wednesdays when i sit down
and do these videos
it's one of the best days of my week i
look forward to it every week
if it ever gets to the point where i'm
like oh man wednesdays
oh socks i gotta go do more videos
if i get to that point i will not have a
lot of success
forcing myself to keep doing videos when
i'm not excited by it
i'll have to stop doing videos swerve
and do something else
and hopefully the day doesn't count but
you never know
so you have to follow your passion okay
and that applies to your life too if
you're if you're
you know looking at dancing or listening
to music or going to parties or whatever
has
something you're passionate about number
two create a schedule
this may not work for everybody but i
like having a structure
i like knowing that i can plan things
out for the week and that everything
will fit
so you know you think about what your
week looks like
monday to friday and then weekends and
think about all the different things
that you want to get done during that
week and schedule them in
put them in your calendars hey this is
what i'm going to spend time on studying
i'm going to spend time on my business
i'm going to spend time with my friends
and fun
and the friends and fun part is just as
important right if you're just all
business
all the time you're going to burn out
and you're not going to like your
business anymore right so it has to be
that mix whatever you feel is right for
you and schedule it in
for me i like knowing it's it's one
having the confidence
and knowing that i have time scheduled
out so
sometimes you can feel overwhelmed right
you have so many things on the go so
many things you have to do so many
people to get back to like when am i
going to do all this stuff i'm going to
go crazy
so i find that having the schedule helps
me because i know okay i don't have to
write back to him today
i don't have to get that proposal done
today but i have time on thursday
to do it i have time that's we're going
to do everything so having that
just gives me more confidence and
reduces my stress level
and uh when you're an entrepreneur it's
good to find things that reduce your
stress level
and so block everything out your
personal and your business
the last one is go with the flow
and this one is breaking rule number two
you will find that there will be times
where you were in a state of flow
where it does not make sense to keep on
your schedule it's worth
breaking your schedule because you're in
a state of flow
and what i mean by that is there will be
times when if you look on a business
perspective there'll be times when
you're just really in the in the groove
like you are
if you're writing something you're
feeling it you're making so much
progress if you're doing videos you're
like you're just you're feeling it right
you're really into it you're doing a
great job
you're all excited you have to stay
there
you have to push everything else off
that day and stay there for as long as
you can there'll be times when
you know you you start doing something
at nine in the morning you wake up or
you look up and it's five at night
and you're still working on it like what
just happened to the day
i remember my first moments of that were
playing games like command and conquer
or civilization you could burn like
eight hours and you don't know where the
day went
but i get that in my business too and
when i'm in that
zone i try to stay there because getting
there is so hard you don't get that
every day
and the stuff you're going to create
when you're in that zone is going to be
so much better than any other time
so you have to cancel i've pushed
meetings i've pushed other appointments
i've pushed other projects because i'm
in the flow on something and i really
enjoy doing it and i know what i'm
creating is going to be
amazing so don't fool yourself to say ah
you know what this schoolwork i'm in the
flow i'm doing so well
i'm going to keep going on it that's bs
you know you don't trick yourself
but when you're really in that zone and
you know when you're in it you've been
there before
you don't get that every day when you're
in that zone you have to keep going
and that can also apply to your personal
life so there's been days where
i'm working on my business and i'm on my
schedule and
uh you know it's just i'm not feeling it
for some
some reason today just i'm not i can't
get in it i i'm struggling with
everything i'm doing
and i look outside and it's a beautiful
day and i just feel like going for a
walk
you know like enjoy the day outside
because because i am not getting
progress on my business
the right answer at least for me is not
push through
grind it out create crappy work that i'm
just gonna have to fix the next day
and then resent my business because i
missed out on a great day
i might go out and enjoy the day and
i'll feel better
and i'll feel happy that i'm an
entrepreneur and i can set my own time
and the next day i come back and i get
to work i'll be in a much better mood
much better space and able to create
something amazing
again so you have to follow the flow you
have to follow your momentum but stick
within a schedule when you're not on
your flow if that makes sense
okay so number one follow your passion
number two create a schedule that works
for you and it's okay if that schedule
changes so if you feel like you're
you're doing something that's working
for a couple months and then it doesn't
feel right anymore
change the schedule up i change my
schedule a lot
every couple months i'm changing my
schedule around a little bit and then
three go with the flow
and when you're really feeling something
something amazing is happening right now
you have to stay in that zone
and not let anything keep you distracted
i hope that helps those are my tips you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below
let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath if you have a
question for me
leave it below i'll make a video
response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon
you